[Have you ever cheated in an exam?]
Now to one group of subjects, we told them,
"Only other students will see your answers."
To another group of subjects, we told them,
"Students and faculty will see your answers."
Transparency. Notification. And sure enough, this worked,
in the sense that the first group of subjects
were much more likely to disclose than the second.
It makes sense, right?
But then we added the misdirection.
We repeated the experiment with the same two groups,
this time adding a delay
between the time we told subjects
how we would use their data
and the time we actually started answering the questions.
How long a delay do you think we had to add
in order to nullify the inhibitory effect
of knowing that faculty would see your answers?
Ten minutes?
Five minutes?
One minute?
How about 15 seconds?
Fifteen seconds were sufficient to have the two groups
disclose the same amount of information,
as if the second group now no longer cares
for faculty reading their answers.
Now I have to admit that this talk so far
may sound exceedingly gloomy,
but that is not my point.
In fact, I want to share with you the fact that
there are alternatives.
The way we are doing things now is not the only way
they can done, and certainly not the best way
they can be done.
When someone tells you, "People don't care about privacy,"
consider whether the game has been designed
and rigged so that they cannot care about privacy,
and coming to the realization that these manipulations occur
is already halfway through the process
of being able to protect yourself.
When someone tells you that privacy is incompatible
with the benefits of big data,
consider that in the last 20 years,
researchers have created technologies
to allow virtually any electronic transactions
to take place in a more privacy-preserving manner.
We can browse the Internet anonymously.
We can send emails that can only be read
by the intended recipient, not even the NSA.
We can have even privacy-preserving data mining.
In other words, we can have the benefits of big data
while protecting privacy.
Of course, these technologies imply a shifting
of cost and revenues
between data holders and data subjects,
which is why, perhaps, you don't hear more about them.
Which brings me back to the Garden of Eden.
There is a second privacy interpretation
of the story of the Garden of Eden
which doesn't have to do with the issue
of Adam and Eve feeling naked
and feeling ashamed.
You can find echoes of this interpretation
in John Milton's "Paradise Lost."
In the garden, Adam and Eve are materially content.
They're happy. They are satisfied.
However, they also lack knowledge
and self-awareness.
The moment they eat the aptly named
fruit of knowledge,
that's when they discover themselves.
They become aware. They achieve autonomy.
The price to pay, however, is leaving the garden.
So privacy, in a way, is both the means
and the price to pay for freedom.
Again, marketers tell us
that big data and social media
are not just a paradise of profit for them,
but a Garden of Eden for the rest of us.
We get free content.
We get to play Angry Birds. We get targeted apps.
But in fact, in a few years, organizations
will know so much about us,
they will be able to infer our desires
before we even form them, and perhaps
buy products on our behalf
before we even know we need them.
Now there was one English author
who anticipated this kind of future
where we would trade away
our autonomy and freedom for comfort.
Even more so than George Orwell,
the author is, of course, Aldous Huxley.
In "Brave New World," he imagines a society
where technologies that we created
originally for freedom
end up coercing us.
However, in the book, he also offers us a way out
of that society, similar to the path
that Adam and Eve had to follow to leave the garden.
In the words of the Savage,
regaining autonomy and freedom is possible,
although the price to pay is steep.
So I do believe that one of the defining fights
of our times will be the fight
for the control over personal information,
the fight over whether big data will become a force
for freedom,
rather than a force which will hiddenly manipulate us.
Right now, many of us
do not even know that the fight is going on,
but it is, whether you like it or not.
And at the risk of playing the serpent,
I will tell you that the tools for the fight
are here, the awareness of what is going on,
and in your hands,
just a few clicks away.
Thank you.
(Applause)